a two-way Anova is a statistical method
used to test the effect of two
categorical variables on a continuous
variable and what about the assumptions
in a two-way Anova for the test results
to be valid several assumptions must be
met number one normality the data within
the groups should be normally
distributed or alternatively the
residual should be normally distributed
this can be checked with a quantile
quantile plot Number Two homogeneity of
variances the variance of data in groups
should be equal this can be checked with
the Lin test number three Independence
the measurements should be independent
I.E the measured value of one group
should not be influenced by the measured
value of another group number four
measurement level the dependent variable
should have a matrix level I hope you
enjoyed the video and see you next
time